hello everybody my name is Nyan I'm the
black female engineer I provides content
for you and aspiring software engineers
and oh my goodness today is a doozy
because we are going to be talking about
tech layoffs now if you don't know
anything about this subject don't worry
I have you covered but also like maybe
we should step outside like once in a
while check out the scenery and all that
because this news has been filling all
of my social media at least as of today
January 21st 2023 118
000 Tech workers have been laid off and
I'm talking top company layoffs meta
Google Microsoft Amazon we already know
about all the mess going on at Twitter
and I wanted to just be a One-Stop shop
of okay what's going on why are these
layoffs happening how long will they
happen for how are the people being laid
off affected but then also how are the
people who have not yet joined Tech but
are looking to are learning to code our
University our encoding boot camps all
that how are they now being affected by
those layoffs
[Music]
now let me start with a quick rundown of
what has been happening yesterday
January 20th Google announced that its
plans to lay off 12
000 of their Workforce Now if you think
that's a lot look at these other numbers
Microsoft is set to lay off 10 000
employees in Amazon 18
000 of their employees now a quick note
with Amazon it looks to be primarily
focused on HR and sales employees and
not so much Tech workers but still 18
000 is a lot meta is set to lay off 11
000 of its workers which is actually the
most significant round of layoffs meta
has ever gone through this amounts to 13
of its entire staff and finally
Salesforce cutting off 10 of his staff
laying off 7 000 of his workers now in
talking about layoffs a lot of comments
that I'll see is people saying oh well
they're okay because they have sevens
packages let's talk about what those
look like for some of these companies
starting with Facebook they have
provided employees with 16 weeks of
severance along with two weeks for every
year that they worked for facebook slash
meta they also are provided the
opportunity to invest their restricted
share units along with health insurance
coverage for a predetermined amount of
time although right now I'm actually not
sure what that time is for retail
workers at Amazon within the United
States people who have been laid off are
actually going to be provided with 60
days of pay and benefits staying on the
payroll even though they are not
expected to keep on working after that
it's noted that they will receive
severance pay as well however the amount
is not yet known to me or the public I'm
not sure so far it looks like Salesforce
has the best package severance package
because they are offering laid off
employees nearly five months of pay
their severance package also includes
six months of health coverage and two
months of outplacement support if you
don't know what outplacement support is
it's basically a company's Career
Services they help with the resumes and
interviewing and really just getting the
employee or previous employee placed at
another job now thinking about those
previous comments again where people are
like okay well they're fine because they
have X Y and Z of severance and packages
and all that
16 weeks isn't much five months isn't
much especially when you have a family a
home an apartment looking at why all of
this is happening right now there are
three main things to look at one coveted
habits now is 2022 and
the actions that consumers had during
2020 and 2021
tech companies based on that covet
happened and people started working from
home people started online shopping
online spending not traveling as much
and all of these different things to
acclimate to this new world we lived in
well top companies like meta like Google
they banked on these actions these
consumer actions being the new way of
the land of the world Etc and so they
hired like crazy another reason there
was a hiring surge was because now that
everything was moving online companies
needed added support for the increased
demand in technology one big example of
this is Amazon in 2020 their Workforce
swelled to about 1.6 million individuals
previously their Workforce was at around
000. so they basically doubled and when
we think about yeah everything we were
doing in 2020 shopping online getting
groceries online the retail bubble and
Company is like Amazon and Salesforce
they experience just so much consumer
demand so it makes sense that they
expanded however like I said before the
prediction of oh this is going to be how
consumers operate from now on oh my
goodness that that was the that was the
wrong one the second reason for these
Cuts is well inflation due to the
impacts inflation has had on consumers
consumers have less flexibility they
have less uh of a say as to where their
money goes in June 2022 food prices
increased 10.4 percent which is the
largest increase since 1981. energy
Prices rose over 40 percent the largest
increase since 1980 and so overall
consumers budgets they are strapped
because now money that could have been
going towards retail and Amazon shopping
is going to things like groceries and
gas meaning overall companies Revenue
use are decreasing their share prices
are decreasing and now they need to find
some way to get back that income and
then finally the third I think biggest
reason that we are experiencing these
layoffs today is because in April of
2021 Apple made a huge change to his
privacy controls now although really
great for just individuals and owners of
Apple products this was so harmful for
top tech companies because now they
couldn't provide targeted ads to
Consumers and companies like facebook
slash meta they rely heavily on ads to
get their revenue and so these three
things combined obviously controls
changing the rise of inflation and also
the habits of consumers changing from
2020 to how we are now really just going
back to pre-pandemic habits it has
created this burst of yeah the tech
bubble now it's not all bad
depending on who you are actually it
might be all bad but if you are a person
who either works in a tech startup or
owns a tech startup yo textiles are
actually a big winner in all of this
because now we have previous meta and
Google and Amazon employees looking to
get a job well startups are hiring they
have access now to top developers from
all around the country and honestly this
may actually be a win-win for those
developers and startups because pretty
historically startups are used to
providing alternative benefits to combat
the lack of financial benefits they can
provide their workers this includes
things like four day work weeks and
unlimited vacation days so now it can
actually be a win-win because these
developers who many of them I'm sure are
used to a very rigid work structure and
what I'm predicting will happen is they
will experience a level of one
responsibility to to impact and three
flexibility that they hadn't in their
previous roles and so hopefully that is
a nice little bright side for anyone who
is watching this who has been laid off
from a big tech company or a tech
company in general now the question is
what happens to individuals like me who
are looking to or were looking to enter
the space from a previous background
whether through a coding Boot Camp or
self-learning Etc well a big Trend
that's been observed is the rise of
contract work in January 2021 so about
what two years ago only six percent of
tech jobs were for contract work now
that number has gone up to 20 percent
hiring contractors in lieu of employees
is obviously great for companies because
this means extra cost savings because
now they don't need to typically pay for
things like health care or time off but
it can also be a really great thing for
contractors themselves being a
contractor means added flexibility added
experience across multiple different
jobs and industries and also the ability
to work on your professional growth by
your own needs and buy your own uh
what's the word buy your own standards
and so if you are currently looking to
learn to code would get into Tech please
please please do not be discouraged by
this everything that's been going on in
terms of layoffs and just the seaming uh
what's the word just chaos going on
right now it's been experienced before
layoffs have occurred before and still
somehow Tech is still the sector that
survives it all please please continue
to focus on your learning and really
focus on your Professional Profile that
means showing your capabilities through
portfolio projects half a pounds open
source contributions and like before
contract work that is going to be the
thing that allows you to Prevail past
all of this and so I really really hope
this video was informative that it was
helpful let me know if it was in the
comments below and yeah we're going to
be talking about this over the next
couple weeks and months Etc but again
stay hopeful stay optimistic because at
the end of the day Tech we need tech and
we need you to learn coding because
that's what lets this role continue to
go around so thank you so much for
joining and I'll talk to you later bye
y'all